around most of major league baseball the
opener has been a thing of a pass this
year but uh not in tampa bay no surprise
and john curtis who saved last night's
game will throw the first pitch tonight
gene segura next pitch sugar swings and
shoots it left side diving stops
tsutsugo gets up throws to first and the
ball comes off the glove of brasso
and it'll go into foul territory
mccutchen slides home and he
is safe as the phillies get a run on the
board in the first
tsutsugo's throw couldn't be handled by
brasso
and the throw home was just a little bit
late and mccutchen slides in safely
zach wheeler 4-1 2-6-7 era on the year
coming off as
what you would consider his worst star
as a philly next pitch is swung on
grounded to short
deedee is up with it underhand flipped
to kingery there's one throw to first is
low but it's dug out by bowm and there's
the
6-4-3 double play
here's a swing and a miss by kinger he's
out on strikes and that
is out number two here in the second
inning here's a 2-1
right to brasso line up at exactly the
right spot
yarborough three up and three down
this pitch is swung on grounded towards
short petey gregorius up with it flips
to second for one throw to first
in time another double play make it 13
for zach wheeler this year
this dumps into the gap kiermeier having
a race all the way to the base of the
wall mccutcheon
burning into second base he's making the
turn
the throw coming into third base not
nearly in time it's a lead off
triple for andrew mccutchen they're
gonna question whether the ball got
lodged in the bottom of that fence at
center field and see if that has
anything to do with
putting the runner at second base they
will put mccutchen at second base that
ball
was clearly wedged under the wall jt
ramuto mccutchen at second and two down
mccutcheon off second and the pitch line
drive right center for a base hit
great jump by mccutcheon around 30 heads
home here's caremeyer's throw to the
plate
cenino's got it they tag him out another
spectacular play defensively by kevin
carmeyer
keeps the phillies off the board
next pitch swing at him as blew him away
98 mile an hour festival and there's the
first strikeout for
zach wieder and the pitch swung on and
missed he got him
changed up on him and zunino is down on
strikes
there's back to back strike
oslin cuts through it for route number
two
a hack at a pitch up in the zone
back-to-back strikeouts and he strands
that
lead-off bunt base hit from gene segura
now the rays have a runner in scoring
position for the first time tonight
chris
hugo clean up hitting third baseman
[Applause]
he slaps this on the ground into left
field
lau is rounding he's on his way home
and he glides across the plate and this
is a tied game of the fourth
this is andrew mccutchen he is yet to be
retired swings and hits one deep
left field going back is margot he's at
the wall he leaps he can't get it it's
gone
and andrew mccutchen has gone deep to
straight away left
it's his 10th home run of the season and
the phillies retake the lead
it's 2-1 then he is now a triple shy of
the cycle
[Applause]
swinging to miss and kiermeier strikeout
victim number five tonight for zach
wheeler
wheeler's 3-2 cuts through some high
heat
two outs and a runner still at second
now it's up to mike zamino
the pitch to zanino here's a swing and a
line drive in the left field
that's a base hit here comes margot
around third he will score on the rbi
single
by mike zenino it's two to two brandon
lowell bat brandon reaching on a
fielder's choice and then
walking and scoring the ray's other run
ground ball into left field
zanino rounding chugging home he scores
standing
brandon lau with two outs puts the raise
in front three to two in the bottom of
the fifth so here's willie with two on
and two out two oh pitch on its way to
willy he swings and drives one
into center field this is gonna get down
for a base hit a rosarina
flying around third he will score lau on
his way to third he's going to get there
and then following up to second base as
william adamus on the throw
the raise lead is now four to two well
this is what the phillies needed they
got
the heart of the order coming up with
first and second nobody out the pitch to
harper swinging a ground ball through
the right side of base
hit into right center field coming home
as mccutchen he will score without a
throw
and bryce harper with an rbi single
makes it a one-run ball game and the
line keeps moving for the fills
wieder again the 2-2 swung on and so
flared into right kingery going out
dives and he makes this catch
no doubt about it scott kingery on the
turf and shallow right lays out for one
and he takes a blue base hit and some
potential trouble away
for zach wheeler aaron slagers had a
30-pitch seventh inning but only give up
one run
and he remains in to try to save it
for pete fairbanks
on the ground tozuga wow on to first
in time for the double play
[Applause]
camden easy catch by lau
rays have won the first two games
against the phillies